This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Greek mythology is filled with stories of violence, anger, and hatred. Take the tale of the goddess Medea. To distract her father as she fled with her lover, Medea killed her brother, cut up his body, and scattered the pieces behind her. Then there's the god Kronos, who devoured five of his children at birth to ward off a prophecy that one of them would eventually overthrow him. For a land blessed with exceptional sunshine and good wine, Greece's home to a striking number of tales about incest, brutality, and bloodthirsty revenge.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。希腊神话中充满了暴力、愤怒和仇恨的故事。以美狄亚女神的传说为例。为了在与情人私奔时分散父亲的注意力，美狄亚杀死了自己的弟弟，将他的尸体切碎，并把碎片抛在身后。还有克洛诺斯神，他在孩子出生时就吞食了五个孩子，以抵御一个关于他们中有人最终会推翻他的预言。对于一片拥有充足阳光和美酒的土地来说，希腊却有着惊人数量关于乱伦、残暴和嗜血复仇的故事。
Thousands of years ago, the Greek philosopher Aristotle had a theory of why this was. In poetics, he suggested that the goal of art was something he called, catharsis. Writing, watching, and reenacting tragedy was good for the soul. It was a form of healing. The idea that stories can be a form of therapy has carried over into modern times. Sigmund Freud explored the idea.
几千年前，希腊哲学家亚里士多德对这种现象有一个理论。在《诗学》中，他提出艺术的目标是他所称的“宣泄”。写作、观看和重演悲剧对灵魂有益。这是一种治愈形式。故事可以作为一种治疗手段的观点一直延续到现代。西格蒙德·弗洛伊德曾探讨过这一理念。
Psychoanalysis involves understanding the self as a series of stories. After Freud fell out of favor, researchers and counselors have continued to explore the role that stories play in our mental wellbeing. This week on Hidden Brain, how understanding the stories of our lives and rewriting them can change us forever.
精神分析涉及将自我理解为一系列故事。在弗洛伊德不再受宠后，研究人员和咨询师继续探索故事在我们心理健康中所扮演的角色。本周的《Hidden Brain》，我们将探讨理解我们人生的故事并重写它们如何能永远改变我们。
A quick heads up. Today's episode touches on trauma and how we cope with it. There are references to suicide and revenge. Rachel first met Greg in California. They were skydiving. They were at what's known as the drop zone, where skydivers gather after a jump. He was funny, he was kind, he was intelligent. He was also good looking. We are using first names to protect the privacy of people in this story. He has beautiful eyes, kind face, wonderful sense of humor.
温馨提示。今天的节目涉及创伤以及我们如何应对创伤。其中提到了自杀和复仇。瑞秋最初是在加利福尼亚州遇到格雷格的。他们当时在跳伞。他们身处所谓的“降落区”，那是跳伞者跳伞后聚集的地方。他风趣、善良、聪明。他还长得很帅。我们使用名字来保护故事中人物的隐私。他有一双美丽的眼睛，一张和蔼的脸，还有极好的幽默感。
Skydivers tend to be a lot of A-type personalities, a lot of ego, but he wasn't like that. He didn't have this need to be the center of attention. I found that appealing. Rachel started to see more of Greg, and she noticed that he made a point of putting himself on the same jumps she was on. So one day, he was sitting on the grass having a lunch. I came over with an extra mountain dew or some kind of soda and we sat down and just started making small talk. Shortly after that first chat, they started dating.
跳伞者往往有很多A型人格，自尊心很强，但他不是那样的人。他不需要成为关注的焦点。我觉得这一点很吸引人。瑞秋开始更多地见到格雷格，她注意到他特意让自己参加她所在的同一批跳伞。所以有一天，他坐在草地上吃午饭。我带着一瓶额外的激浪饮料或某种汽水走过去，我们坐下来开始闲聊。那次谈话后不久，他们就开始约会了。
Three months in, Rachel was doing a jump during some rough weather. And I came in on some very windy conditions and had a little accident and nothing major but I did break my wrist. Greg offered to come over and take care of her while she healed. We spent a lot of time together at that point and I was tickled and delighted. Greg never moved out and soon they were engaged. About a year later Rachel and Greg went skydiving in Arizona. She recorded some of the jumps on her GoPro. It was still very early in the morning.
三个月后，瑞秋在天气恶劣的情况下进行了一次跳伞。我在风很大的情况下着陆，出了一点小事故，虽然没什么大碍，但我确实摔断了手腕。格雷格主动提出过来照顾她，直到她康复。那时我们花了很多时间在一起，我感到非常开心和愉悦。格雷格再也没有搬走，不久他们就订婚了。大约一年后，瑞秋和格雷格去亚利桑那州跳伞。她用GoPro记录了一些跳伞过程。当时还是清晨。
It's an amazing experience. Ready, go! You have about a minute of free fall and then you break away and then you deploy your canopies. After landing, they quickly went up again. Thousands of feet above the Arizona desert, they jumped. We did another free-fly jump with two other people. We did what's called a for-way. You have to come in in a certain pattern. You have to pick your spot and you do a landing pattern. When they broke away for the landing, Greg went first.
这是一种奇妙的体验。准备，走！你有大约一分钟的自由落体时间，然后你脱离并打开降落伞。着陆后，他们很快又上去了。在亚利桑那州沙漠上空几千英尺处，他们跳了下去。我们和其他两个人一起做了另一次自由飞行跳伞。我们做了所谓的“四人编队”。你必须以特定的模式进入。你必须选好你的位置，然后按照着陆模式进行。当他们脱离准备着陆时，格雷格先走了。
As he neared the ground, Rachel noticed something that looked like a little tornado below her. The weather as it warms up can create dust devils. Greg was headed straight into one. Just before she made her own landing, Rachel caught one last glimpse of him. I can see him completely split on the ground. I can see his canopy is completely collapsed. It shouldn't have been collapsed at that point. I can see people running toward him.
当他接近地面时，瑞秋注意到他下方出现了一个看起来像小龙卷风的东西。天气变暖时会产生尘卷风。格雷格正径直冲向一个尘卷风。就在她自己着陆前，瑞秋最后瞥了他一眼。我看到他整个人摔在地上。我看到他的降落伞完全坍塌了。在那个阶段它本不该坍塌的。我看到人们向他跑去。
Rachel landed safely and rushed to Greg. He's faces contorted in pain. They've just pulled off his shoe. He has a bone sticking out of his foot. He has a busted femur, both fear broken. Greg was medevac to a trauma center. Rachel followed by car. He was already in surgery when she got there. His first surgery to repair his femur, and they put a rod down his leg. It turns out that the initial injury, which was the femur
瑞秋安全着陆并冲向格雷格。他的脸因痛苦而扭曲。他们刚脱掉他的鞋子。他有一根骨头从脚里戳出来。他的股骨断了，两条腿都断了。格雷格被医疗直升机送往创伤中心。瑞秋开车跟随。她到那里时，他已经在手术中了。他的第一次手术是修复股骨，他们在他的腿里植入了一根钢钉。事实证明，最初的损伤，也就是股骨
fracture, was the easiest to fix. It turns out that his feet and his leg and his lumbar area would all just have issues. Greg was sent home to continue his healing. A primary care physician took over his case. She was new, a replacement for Greg's long-time doctor who recently retired. Greg's biggest issue now was pain. It was almost unbearable. Still, they felt sure that with time and good medical care, it would ease. We felt like we were beating the odds.
骨折，是最容易修复的。事实证明，他的脚、腿和腰部区域都会出现问题。格雷格被送回家继续康复。一位初级保健医生接手了他的病例。她是新来的，接替了格雷格最近退休的长期医生。格雷格现在最大的问题是疼痛。这几乎是无法忍受的。尽管如此，他们仍然确信，随着时间和良好的医疗护理，疼痛会减轻。我们觉得我们正在克服困难。
He kept his feet and it was just, it was hard, but we were gonna get through it. But Rachel says the new doctor was cautious. Doctors who treat pain have to balance competing goals. They want to minimize pain as much as possible, but as a recent opioid epidemic shows, the strongest drugs can also harm patients and lead to deadly addictions. How far do you go with medications? How fast? These are tough questions that often do not have clear-cut answers. She had a protocol.
他保住了双脚，这虽然很难，但我们能挺过去。但瑞秋说这位新医生很谨慎。治疗疼痛的医生必须平衡相互冲突的目标。他们想尽可能减轻疼痛，但正如最近的阿片类药物流行所显示的那样，最强效的药物也可能伤害患者并导致致命的成瘾。你在药物治疗上走多远？多快？这些都是棘手的问题，通常没有明确的答案。她有一套方案。
I remember her showing it to me once, and she was going to try each drug. Well each drug has to be approved. He has to try it for a few weeks. If it doesn't work, we have to come in. We have to look at the next one. Nothing. Eased Greg's pain. He told me on a regular basis it was like someone was stabbing
我记得她有一次给我看，她打算尝试每一种药。嗯，每种药都必须经过批准。他必须尝试几周。如果不起作用，我们必须去复诊。我们必须考虑下一种。什么都没有。减轻格雷格的痛苦。他经常告诉我，感觉就像有人在用刀刺
him with a knife and turning the knife and he just was constant. This is the kind of pain, you know, is a nightmare. Rachel felt powerless. Meanwhile Greg got worse and worse. He stopped getting out of bed. He was gradually not eating. He was curling up in a ball. He was just shutting down. And he would tell me about how much pain he was in. And then he wouldn't talk for the rest of the day.
他，还在转动刀子，这种痛苦是持续不断的。你知道，这种痛苦是一场噩梦。瑞秋感到无能为力。与此同时，格雷格的情况越来越糟。他不再起床。他逐渐不吃东西。他蜷缩成一团。他只是在自我封闭。他会告诉我他有多痛苦。然后他一整天都不再说话。
Rachel says Greg told her he couldn't endure the pain and that he began to talk about killing himself. He says, I feel like I'm scratching my fingernails on rocks trying to pull myself out of a well and I just keep sinking further and further in and I want to end it. ended. Rachel found a pilot who agreed to fly Greg to a hospital in Mexico. He could receive stronger pain medication there. But Rachel says that doctor said it would take a few weeks to transfer his medical records. I was so we don't have a few weeks. This is an emergency. He's not going to make it. He isn't such terrible condition. And again, it was like talking to a brick wall. As the doctor turned to leave, Rachel remembers doing something unexpected.
瑞秋说格雷格告诉她他无法忍受这种痛苦，并开始谈论自杀。他说，我觉得自己就像在岩石上抓挠指甲，试图把自己从井里拉出来，但我却不断地越陷越深，我想结束这一切。结束了。瑞秋找到了一位飞行员，同意将格雷格飞往墨西哥的一家医院。他可以在那里接受更强效的止痛药。但瑞秋说那位医生说转移他的医疗记录需要几周时间。我当时说我们没有几周时间。这是紧急情况。他撑不过去的。他的情况太糟糕了。而且再一次，就像对着一堵墙说话。当医生转身离开时，瑞秋记得自己做了一件意想不到的事。
She fell to her knees. And I looked at her and I looked at her staff. There was a couple other women in the room and I said, please, this is so important, he's not going to make it, he's in so much pain. Please, I'm begging you, help him." And they just looked at me, the couple of other gals they looked upset, but they didn't say anything and she just looked at me and she says, we have to wait for this to work. And she turned around and she just looked at me and she says we have to wait for this to work. And she turned around and she left. Five days later, Greg hauled himself into a car. He got himself to the top of a tall building and he flung himself over the edge.
她跪了下来。我看着她，看着她的工作人员。房间里还有另外几个女人，我说：“求求你们，这太重要了，他撑不过去了，他太痛苦了。求求你们，我求求你们，帮帮他。”她们只是看着我，那几个女人看起来很难过，但她们什么也没说，她只是看着我说：“我们必须等待这个方案起效。”然后她转身离开了。五天后，格雷格把自己拖进了一辆车。他爬上了一栋高楼的顶端，然后从边缘跳了下去。
He called 911 right before he did it so that he wouldn't be laying there. He didn't want to upset anybody. He left a note at the house. It was a scrawl in this crazy handwriting. It was basically, I don't want to die. I'm so sorry to go. I love you, but I just can't take it anymore. The first call Rachel made was to the doctor.
他在跳下去之前拨打了911，这样他就不会躺在那里。他不想让任何人感到不安。他在家里留了一张字条。那是用疯狂的笔迹潦草写下的。基本上是说，我不想死。我很抱歉要走了。我爱你，但我实在受不了了。瑞秋打的第一个电话是给那位医生的。
I got her on the phone and I told her, I said, you know, he killed himself. This is your fault. Rachel can't remember how the doctor replied, but she says it wasn't what she needed to hear. I was so upset with her. I kept feeling like this didn't have to go this way. You could have helped him. We could have, you know, maybe lost his feet or something, but he could have been here and he certainly could have been kept comfortable. I mean, nobody treats a person like this. We don't treat animals like this.
我接通了她的电话，我告诉她，我说，你知道吗，他自杀了。这是你的错。瑞秋不记得医生是怎么回答的，但她说那不是她想听到的。我对她非常生气。我一直觉得事情本不必这样。你本可以帮他的。我们可能，你知道，也许会失去他的双脚什么的，但他本可以活下来，而且他肯定可以保持舒适。我的意思是，没有人会这样对待一个人。我们连对待动物都不会这样。
We do not know the name of Greg's doctor, and our story is not about whether she did something wrong. Our story is about how Rachel saw things and what happened next in her mind. As the days passed, Rachel's grief turned to rage. She began fantasizing about revenge. Rachel knew she and the doctor lived in the same town. She kept thinking about what would happen if she bumped into her at the store. I imagined that I would see her in an aisle and I would walk up to her and she'd see me and I'd see her and I'd spit in her face. I'd just nail her right in the middle of her
我们不知道格雷格医生的名字，我们的故事也不是关于她是否做错了什么。我们的故事是关于瑞秋如何看待这些事情，以及她脑海中接下来发生了什么。随着日子一天天过去，瑞秋的悲伤变成了愤怒。她开始幻想复仇。瑞秋知道她和医生住在同一个镇上。她一直在想，如果她在商店里偶遇她会发生什么。我想象着我会在过道里看到她，我会走向她，她会看到我，我也会看到她，然后我会朝她脸上吐口水。我会直接朝她脸上
face and I'd look at her in the eye while she would look shocked. And then I would slap her. And, you know, maybe I would throw a few more punches. And I would tell her, I would tell her how awful she was. And how awful she treated this beautiful human being. And I wanted her to be afraid. I wanted her to be sorry. In some kind of twisted way, I wanted her to get how she'd taken a beautiful human being from the world. That she'd let a beautiful human being go through incalculable suffering. For what? Why?
吐过去，我会盯着她的眼睛，看着她露出震惊的表情。然后我会扇她耳光。而且，你知道，也许我会再打几拳。我会告诉她，我会告诉她她有多糟糕。以及她对待这个美丽的人类有多么糟糕。我想让她感到害怕。我想让她感到后悔。以某种扭曲的方式，我想让她明白她是如何从这个世界上夺走了一个美丽的人。她让一个美丽的人经历了无法估量的痛苦。为了什么？为什么？
When Rachel did this, when she thought about confronting the doctor in the supermarket, something surprising happened. I would like feel a loosening up of like all the tension in my body as I would think about it. It was like a fantasy. It was like, if you have a fantasy about a vacation and you go off and you imagine how wonderful a beach is going to be, let's say, and you can feel how you relax and it was sort of like that. I would imagine how
当瑞秋这样做时，当她想到在超市里与医生对质时，发生了一件令人惊讶的事情。我会感觉到身体里所有的紧张感都松弛了下来，每当我想到这件事的时候。这就像一种幻想。这就像，如果你对假期有幻想，你想象海滩会有多美，比如说，你可以感觉到你是如何放松的，这有点像那样。我会想象
satisfying it would be for her to suffer some little bit of what Greg suffered. The more detailed and vivid her fantasy became, the more it soothed Rachel. I could run this whole movie in my mind. I could see her at the market. I could see the shock on her face. I could feel the satisfaction of hurting her, I mean emotionally, and somehow that was going to help me, somehow that was going to make it better. As the days passed, Rachel starts wondered even further.
如果她能承受一点点格雷格所受的痛苦，那该有多令人满足。她的幻想越详细、越生动，就越能抚慰瑞秋。我可以在脑海中放映整部电影。我可以看到她在市场里。我可以看到她脸上的震惊。我可以感受到伤害她的满足感，我是说在情感上，不知何故这会帮助我，不知何故这会让事情变得好一点。随着日子一天天过去，瑞秋开始想得更远。
And I was getting a lot of relief out of running this scenario in my mind. And the more involved it got, the more it occurred to me that, well, if I follow through, I'll get even more relief. Rachel eventually confided her fantasy to a grief counselor. And she jumped on it. And she basically said, you need to stop thinking about that right now. You've got this way to plan out. Do you know what will happen if you do that? You will get arrested. You could lose your job.
我在脑海中运行这个场景时得到了很多解脱。而且它变得越复杂，我就越觉得，好吧，如果我付诸行动，我会得到更多的解脱。瑞秋最终向一位悲伤咨询师吐露了她的幻想。她立刻抓住了重点。她基本上说，你现在需要停止想这件事。你已经把这个计划想得这么周全了。你知道如果你那样做会发生什么吗？你会因为被捕。你可能会丢掉工作。
And I remember being shocked and I remember thinking it was going to be difficult to stop thinking about it. And once the therapist asks you to let this go, you said it was difficult in the session, but in the days that followed, what happened? I did a lot of journaling and I realized that I had been caught up in some kind of, I don't know, crazy grief response, crazy loop. I realized that if I, counsel hadn't talked to me, I think I had the potential to act on it. The fantasy just kept getting richer and richer as each, you know, few days would go by. And I ultimately decided that for the rest of my life, if I think she's anywhere nearby, I will leave.
我记得当时很震惊，也记得当时觉得要停止想这件事会很困难。当治疗师让你放下这件事时，你说在咨询中这很困难，但在接下来的日子里，发生了什么？我做了很多日记记录，我意识到我陷入了某种，我不知道，疯狂的悲伤反应，疯狂的循环。我意识到如果咨询师没有和我谈过，我想我有可能会付诸行动。随着时间的推移，幻想变得越来越丰富。我最终决定，在我的余生中，如果我觉得她在附近，我就会离开。
I will just leave. Was Rachel's fantasy of revenge a precursor to her committing a crime? How grief-counselor worried about that? Rachel worried about that too. Such a response is understandable, but it also reflects the larger way many of us think of fantasies, even our own. We react to their content instead of asking about their origins. Rather than seeing them as an imperfect way our minds are responding to trauma, we
我会直接离开。瑞秋的复仇幻想是她犯罪的前兆吗？悲伤咨询师担心这一点吗？瑞秋也担心这一点。这种反应是可以理解的，但它也反映了我们许多人看待幻想的更广泛方式，甚至是看待我们自己的幻想。我们对它们的内容做出反应，而不是询问它们的起源。我们没有把它们看作是我们心灵应对创伤的一种不完美方式，而是
recoil from them because we fear what they might reveal about our inner demons. When we come back, what would happen if we looked at our fantasies with less judgment and more curiosity. So I got into this terrible worked-up state writing it but it was only writing. It's safely contained on that beautiful white frame of the paper. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Once upon a time there was a boy. One day he was exploring the mountains near his home when he saw a small white bird flying to a cave.
因为害怕它们可能揭示我们内心深处的恶魔而退缩。当我们回来时，如果我们以更少的评判和更多的好奇心来看待我们的幻想会怎样。所以我写的时候进入了一种可怕的亢奋状态，但这只是写作。它安全地包含在那张美丽的白纸框架里。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。从前有个男孩。有一天，他在家附近的群山中探险时，看到一只小白鸟飞进了一个洞穴。
He decided to follow it. At first it was easy. The bird was bright against the dark rock walls. But soon the gloom turned into a suffocating blackness. The boy couldn't see the bird anymore. He couldn't see anything. He wasn't sure how to get back out. He turned in a circle, trying to get his bearings.
他决定跟着它。起初很容易。在黑暗的岩壁衬托下，那只鸟很显眼。但很快，阴暗变成了令人窒息的漆黑。男孩再也看不见那只鸟了。他什么也看不见。他不确定该怎么走回去。他在原地转圈，试图辨别方向。
And that is when it happened. The sand beneath his feet began to shift and move and open and then. Okay, let's stop there. You want to know what happens next. The truth is, I don't know. I made up the story to illustrate a point, how narratives can take hold of our attention and draw us in.
就在那时，事情发生了。他脚下的沙子开始移动、翻滚、裂开，然后。好吧，我们停在这里。你想知道接下来会发生什么。事实是，我不知道。我编这个故事是为了说明一个观点，叙事是如何抓住我们的注意力并将我们吸引进去的。
As a lifelong reader, Raymond Mar knows all about the appeal of a good yarn. But as a psychologist at York University in Toronto, he's also interested in why stories have the power to hold us captive. You're in a dreamlike state and you're so deeply immersed within this world that even, you know, if you sort of get jared out of a piece of fiction that you're highly engaged with, it takes a while for you to re-enter the real world. Over the years, Raymond has studied why stories work this way. Why are our minds so attuned to narrative and storytelling? Think about the last really great book you read.
作为一名终身读者，雷蒙德·马尔非常了解好故事的吸引力。但作为多伦多约克大学的心理学家，他也对故事为何有能力让我们着迷感兴趣。你处于一种梦幻般的状态，你深深地沉浸在这个世界中，以至于，你知道，即使你从一部你高度投入的小说中被惊醒，你也需要一段时间才能重新进入现实世界。多年来，雷蒙德研究了故事为何以这种方式运作。为什么我们的思想如此适应叙事和讲故事？想想你读过的最后一本真正的好书。
If someone asked you what you liked about it, chances are your answer will be about how the story made you feel. Raymond says there's a reason for that. This deep sort of immersion in the story, this deep imagination, draws upon the same sort of emotional systems that we use in the real world.
如果有人问你喜欢它什么，你很可能会回答这个故事让你感觉如何。雷蒙德说这是有原因的。这种对故事的深度沉浸，这种深度的想象，利用了我们在现实世界中使用的同样的某种情感系统。
So the sadness that we feel when a character that we care a lot about dies, for example, it's not the same as a real loved one dying, but it's similar enough that it can produce things like tears and the same sort of physiological symptoms of sadness. And we experience this as sadness. Some years ago, Raymond analyzed data from studies in which people were asked to read stories while undergoing brain scans. He found that when we are immersed in a story,
所以，当我们关心的角色死亡时我们感到的悲伤，例如，它与真正的亲人去世不同，但它足够相似，以至于可以产生泪水和同样的悲伤生理症状。我们将其体验为悲伤。几年前，雷蒙德分析了人们在接受脑部扫描时阅读故事的研究数据。他发现，当我们沉浸在故事中时，
our brains respond as if we are part of the fictional world that we are seeing on the page. So if you have someone read a very simple sentence about a person kicking a soccer ball, not only will you see parts of the language network become involved, but you also see activation in the motor cortex, the same part of the brain that we use to actually move our bodies. And more importantly, this activation is quite specific. So you'll only see a part of the motor cortex activated that's related to the lower half of the body. It's worth pausing a moment and underlining this point. When we read about someone kicking a soccer ball, our brain is activated in the same way as if we were actually the ones
我们的大脑反应就好像我们是我们正在阅读的虚构世界的一部分。所以，如果你让某人阅读一个关于一个人踢足球的简单句子，你不仅会看到语言网络的部分参与，还会看到运动皮层的激活，这是我们用来实际移动身体的大脑部分。更重要的是，这种激活是非常具体的。所以你只会看到运动皮层中与身体下半部分相关的部分被激活。值得停顿片刻并强调这一点。当我们读到有人踢足球时，我们大脑的激活方式与我们自己实际
kicking the soccer ball. Raymond began to wonder if something similar happens as our minds process the social challenges that characters encounter in stories. So reading, I believe, it's possible that it presents to us an imagined social world for us to interact with. So it gives to us a representation of human interactions, human psychology that we can then learn from in very safe circumstances. Put another way. Stories give us a chance to experience the real world, without the risks of the real world. They allow us to run different scenarios and to think about the consequences of those
踢足球时是一样的。雷蒙德开始怀疑，当我们的思想处理故事中角色遇到的社会挑战时，是否会发生类似的事情。所以阅读，我相信，它可能为我们提供了一个可以互动的想象社会世界。它为我们提供了一个人类互动、人类心理的表征，我们可以在非常安全的环境中从中学习。换句话说。故事让我们有机会体验现实世界，而没有现实世界的风险。它们允许我们运行不同的场景并思考这些
scenarios. If we are evaluating a move to a different city, for example, we might imagine what it would be like to live in that city, what would be great about it? What would be awful? Stories, daydreams and fantasies in other words allow us to imagine different versions of ourselves. They allow us to ask, what would I do in this situation? How would I react? What kind of a person would I be? Raymond figured that if all of this was true, reading about other characters should make us more insightful people. I had senior colleagues tell me that you're going to find the exact opposite.
场景的后果。例如，如果我们正在评估搬到另一个城市，我们可能会想象住在那个城市会是什么样子，有什么好的？有什么糟糕的？换句话说，故事、白日梦和幻想让我们能够想象不同版本的自己。它们让我们问，在这种情况下我会怎么做？我会如何反应？我会成为什么样的人？雷蒙德认为，如果这一切都是真的，阅读其他角色应该会让我们成为更有洞察力的人。我有资深同事告诉我，你会发现完全相反的结果。
It's people who read a lot that are going to be more socially awkward, they're going to have more difficulty and understand other people. Raymond came up with a study. He tallied the reading habits of volunteers and then had them take a test. It's called the reading the mind in the eyes test. Volunteers were asked to examine the photographs of people's faces. Specifically, the photos showed only people's eyes. Could volunteers tell what emotion the person in the photo was experiencing, using only the expression in their eyes. And what we found was that people who were exposed to more narrative fiction did better on this test of understanding what other people are thinking and feeling and what their mental states are.
读很多书的人会更不善社交，他们在理解他人方面会有更多困难。雷蒙德进行了一项研究。他统计了志愿者的阅读习惯，然后让他们参加了一项测试。这被称为“通过眼睛阅读心灵”测试。志愿者被要求检查人们面部的照片。具体来说，照片只显示了人们的眼睛。志愿者能否仅通过眼睛的表情判断照片中的人正在经历什么情绪？我们发现，接触更多叙事小说的人在理解他人想法、感受及其心理状态的测试中表现更好。
So there was a positive correlation. Now, a correlation is just an association. We don't know that reading books caused people to be better at reading the mental states of other people. It's entirely possible that the reverse could be true, the people that are really good at understanding other people are also interested in fiction because fiction portrays social content, or that some third variable explains the association between these two things. What is clear, however, is that you cannot follow books and movies without being able to skillfully tell what's happening in the minds of various characters.
所以存在正相关。现在，相关性只是一种关联。我们不知道阅读书籍是否导致人们更擅长解读他人的心理状态。完全有可能情况恰恰相反，那些非常擅长理解他人的人也对小说感兴趣，因为小说描绘了社会内容，或者某种第三变量解释了这两者之间的关联。然而，显而易见的是，如果你不能熟练地判断各种角色的内心世界，你就无法跟上书籍和电影的节奏。
Appreciating a story requires you to see the world through the perspectives of other people. It requires empathy. So if John gets into a fight or a conflict with a playmate and then he leaves, you might have to make the inference that he left because he was upset or that he left because he won or that he left because he lost or he left because he was humiliated or any number of different, any number of different mental states. Right, they're all
欣赏一个故事需要你从他人的角度看世界。它需要同理心。所以，如果约翰与玩伴发生争吵或冲突，然后他离开了，你可能必须推断他离开是因为他心烦意乱，或者他离开是因为他赢了，或者他离开是因为他输了，或者他离开是因为他受到了羞辱，或者任何数量的不同的、任何数量的不同的心理状态。对，它们都是
possible. But, you know, in order to make sense of the entire story, you would hopefully have to make correct inferences. So, you're initial inferences. If they don't seem to be consistent with the other events, then you might change your inferences. As we run through what's happening in the minds of various characters, good stories call on us to revise our initial assumptions. They invite us to be flexible. And again, there is an overlap here between what happens in the brain when we read and when we experience things in real life.
可能的。但是，你知道，为了理解整个故事，你希望必须做出正确的推断。所以，你最初的推断。如果它们看起来与其他事件不一致，那么你可能会改变你的推断。当我们审视各种角色的内心世界时，好的故事要求我们修正最初的假设。它们邀请我们变得灵活。同样，这里存在重叠，即当我们阅读时和我们在现实生活中经历事情时，大脑中发生的事情之间存在重叠。
It seems like the brain regions that we employ when we're understanding stories look quite similar to the brain regions that we employ when we're trying to understand other people's mental states, which is a nice piece of evidence, I would say, that's consistent with this idea that when we're reading fiction, we're immersing ourselves in the world of fiction, we're drawing upon the same brain regions, the same network of brain regions that we use when we understand the real world.
似乎我们在理解故事时所采用的大脑区域与我们在试图理解他人心理状态时所采用的大脑区域看起来非常相似，我认为这是一个很好的证据，与这个观点一致，即当我们阅读小说时，我们将自己沉浸在小说的世界中，我们利用的是我们在理解现实世界时使用的相同大脑区域，相同的脑区网络。
This, of course, is the insight that Aristotle had centuries ago. Stories provide us with catharsis, a mechanism to safely explore difficult terrain. You don't actually have to kill your son in real life when you're upset with him. You watch a play and see what happens when a character events her age. Instead of getting hauled up in court for murder, you just sit in a theater for a couple of hours and clap when the curtain comes down. If stories can serve as a safe space
这当然是亚里士多德几个世纪前就有的洞见。故事为我们提供了宣泄，一种安全探索困难领域的机制。当你对儿子感到不满时，你实际上不必在现实生活中杀了他。你观看一场戏剧，看看当一个角色发泄愤怒时会发生什么。你不用因为谋杀而被送上法庭，你只需要在剧院里坐上几个小时，在幕布落下时鼓掌。如果故事可以作为一个安全的空间
to explore trauma and repressed feelings, can they also be used to heal those traumas? All my working life, I focused on research into therapeutic writing, the value, to the personal self of writing, writing journals, poetry, stories. This is educator and therapist, Julie Bolton. She believes therapeutic writing can help people discover and address deeply buried trauma. That's exactly what happens with memories of severe trauma. They get locked up in the memory and you can't access them. And one of the very few ways of accessing those kinds of traumatic
来探索创伤和压抑的情感，它们是否也可以用来治愈那些创伤？我整个职业生涯都专注于治疗性写作的研究，写作、写日记、诗歌、故事对个人自我的价值。这是教育家和治疗师朱莉·博尔顿。她相信治疗性写作可以帮助人们发现并解决深埋的创伤。这正是严重创伤记忆发生的情况。它们被锁在记忆中，你无法访问它们。而访问这些创伤性
memories is through metaphor, I side ways. you can't come straight at them, your mind is so injured by it, it doesn't want you to find it. Gilly tells a story of one student, a doctor we'll call Mark. He took a seminar she was leading for physicians. The only thing I asked this group of doctors to do was to write about a significant event in their life. And this one young man, he shared with us a poem he'd written about how when he was little, how his brother had been run over and killed and the poem is just extraordinarily powerful. I asked Gilly if she'd read a bit of it to us.
记忆的极少数方法之一是通过隐喻，侧面切入。你不能直接面对它们，你的思想被它伤害得太深，它不想让你找到它。吉莉讲述了一个学生的故事，一位我们称之为马克的医生。他参加了她为医生举办的研讨会。我要求这组医生做的唯一一件事就是写下他们生活中发生的一件重大事件。而这个年轻人，他与我们分享了他写的一首诗，关于他小时候他的兄弟是如何被车撞死的故事，这首诗非常震撼。我问吉莉是否可以为我们读一点。
The grown-up stand around watching, grown-ups know what to do, the grown-up stand around watching. Is that Simon lying on the pavement? He's got blondie hair like Simon's. The grown-up stand around watching. A boy's been run over, another kid says. Is that Simon lying on the pavement? He was walking in front of me. The grown-up stand around watching. Mrs. Bailey puts a blanket over him, but I can still see his blondie hair. Later, Mark wrote this about writing the poem. I had never
大人们站在周围看着，大人们知道该做什么，大人们站在周围看着。那是西蒙躺在人行道上吗？他有像西蒙一样的金发。大人们站在周围看着。一个男孩被车撞了，另一个孩子说。那是西蒙躺在人行道上吗？他走在我前面。大人们站在周围看着。贝利太太给他盖上一条毯子，但我仍然能看到他金色的头发。后来，马克写下了关于写这首诗的感受。我从来没有
talked about what I was feeling when Simon died. Now I've written about it I can and do talk about it. Simon and I had had an argument about a fortnight before he died. I'd asked Simon not to walk with me to school. You know what it's like, an older brother wants to be with his own friends and doesn't want to be seen taking care of his little brother. Until I did this writing, I felt guilty about Simon's death, that it was my fault for not allowing him to walk with me. As an adult, that guilt ate away at Mark. It kept him from being the kind of doctor he wanted to be.
谈论过西蒙死时我的感受。现在我写下来了，我可以并且确实在谈论它。西蒙和我在他去世前大约两周吵过架。我曾要求西蒙不要陪我走路上学。你知道那是什么感觉，一个哥哥想和自己的朋友在一起，不想被看到在照顾弟弟。直到我做了这次写作，我一直对西蒙的死感到内疚，觉得是因为我不让他陪我走而导致了我的错。作为一个成年人，那种内疚感一直在折磨着马克。它让他无法成为他想成为的那种医生。
Then he wrote the poem. And he said it's changed my practice of medicine so much because in the past I could not relate to a child who was very ill at all, especially a child who was dying. And after that he could. We all have stories in us, Julie says, stories that need telling. Sometimes, releasing them is enough to bring comfort and peace. But stories also allow us to do something we cannot do in real life. On the page, we can rewrite the stories from our past. We can reframe them. We can invent new characters.
然后他写了那首诗。他说这极大地改变了他的行医方式，因为过去我根本无法与一个病得很重的孩子产生共鸣，尤其是垂死的孩子。在那之后他可以了。朱莉说，我们每个人内心都有故事，需要讲述的故事。有时，释放它们足以带来安慰与平静。但故事也让我们能够做一些我们在现实生活中做不到的事情。在纸上，我们可以重写过去的那些故事。我们可以重构它们。我们可以发明新角色。
We can change how we behaved. We can turn them into fantasies. Instead of walking ahead of a younger brother on the way to school, we can walk alongside the child. We can make anything happen in a story if we want to. And it's one of the things I suggest people do especially of what they've been exploring is something harrowing, tragic, something horrible or something that they've got stuck with and I suggested that they
我们可以改变我们的行为方式。我们可以把它们变成幻想。与其在去学校的路上走在弟弟前面，我们可以和孩子并肩行走。如果我们愿意，我们可以在故事中让任何事情发生。这是我建议人们做的事情之一，特别是如果他们一直在探索的是令人痛苦、悲惨、可怕的事情，或者是他们陷入困境的事情，我建议他们
they try writing it with a different ending, something totally different happening. Asking people to turn their life experiences into fiction comes with another deep psychological benefit. A good story does not have caricatures, like cartoon heroes who always behave like heroes, or villains who are always evil. A good story needs real people, with complex emotions and conflicting impulses. So when you write about events that happen to you, you might find yourself getting into the minds of people who offended you, people who hurt you. You might find yourself asking, why did this person do this? What was their motivation? Storytelling in other words, can become a vehicle for empathy.
尝试用不同的结局写出来，让一些完全不同的事情发生。要求人们将他们的生活经历转化为小说会带来另一个深层的心理益处。一个好的故事没有漫画式的人物，比如总是表现得像英雄的卡通英雄，或者总是邪恶的恶棍。一个好的故事需要真实的人，有着复杂的情感和冲突的冲动。所以当你写下发生在你身上的事件时，你可能会发现自己进入了那些冒犯你、伤害你的人的内心。你可能会发现自己问，为什么这个人会这样做？他们的动机是什么？换句话说，讲故事可以成为同理心的载体。
Julie tells a story of another physician. He started writing a story about his encounter with a child patient and their parents. And he got incredibly worked up writing this because the child had nearly died of meningitis. And the parents were absolutely furious with him because he hadn't diagnosed the meningitis before it became dangerous and the child had to be hospitalised. And I don't know if you know, but meningitis is extremely difficult to diagnose in its first stages. So he wrote the story, he wrote out his
朱莉讲述了另一位医生的故事。他开始写一个关于他与一名儿童患者及其父母相遇的故事。他在写这个故事时变得非常激动，因为那个孩子差点死于脑膜炎。而父母对他非常愤怒，因为他在脑膜炎变得危险之前没有诊断出来，导致孩子不得不住院。我不知道你知不知道，但脑膜炎在初期阶段极难诊断。所以他写了这个故事，写出了他对父母的
fury at the parents who were so angry with him, I'm trying to get him struck off as a physician. And then he thought, well, I'll try what this person person, Julie Bolton, tells us to do, what she advises us to do. I'll write it from the point of view of the parents. I can't see it's going to work, but I'm going to try it. And he did. He started writing the story from the point of view, the perspective of the parents. And he said he had written hardly any words before he sat there in floods of tears and suddenly realized what it was, what was going on here that here were two people
愤怒，他们对他非常生气，试图让他失去医生资格。然后他想，好吧，我会尝试一下这个人，朱莉·博尔顿，告诉我们做的事情，她建议我们做的事情。我会从父母的角度来写。我看不出这会有什么用，但我会试一试。他确实这样做了。他开始从父母的角度、视角写这个故事。他说他还没写几个字，就坐在那里泪流满面，突然意识到发生了什么，这里有两个
who were absolutely terrified. They were angry with him because they've been so scared, their lovely daughter was going to die. And he said, I instantly just felt sympathy and empathy for them. My anger just disappeared from these first few sentences I wrote of writing the story from their point of view. If you decide to try Julie's advice, you don't have to share your story with anyone else. Julie herself has probed some dark memories and allowed herself to say and do things on
绝对被吓坏了的人。他们对他生气是因为他们太害怕了，他们可爱的女儿会死。他说，我立刻就对他们产生了同情和共鸣。我写下从他们角度出发的故事的最初几句话，我的愤怒就消失了。如果你决定尝试朱莉的建议，你不必与任何人分享你的故事。朱莉本人也探究了一些黑暗的记忆，并允许自己在
the page that she would never dream of saying or doing in real life. I wrote all these absolutely awful things and I allowed myself to do it because I knew nobody else needed ever read them. So I got into this terrible, worked-up state, writing it, but it was only writing. It's safely contained on that beautiful white frame of the paper. When we come back, a woman who used fiction to heal deep psychological wounds and turned her fantasies into a lucrative career. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
纸上说出和做出她在现实生活中做梦都不会说或做的事情。我写下了所有这些绝对糟糕的事情，我允许自己这样做，因为我知道永远不需要其他人阅读它们。所以我写的时候进入了一种可怕的亢奋状态，但这只是写作。它安全地包含在那张美丽的白纸框架里。当我们回来时，一位利用小说治愈深层心理创伤并将她的幻想转化为利润丰厚职业的女性。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Krista Sandor's early childhood is a blur of different homes in different places. We lived in Pennsylvania, Ohio, Texas, Illinois, and then we got to Kansas City when I was 10, so that's a lot of moving. During that 10th year her parents divorced. Christa's dad moved to Chicago and Christa stayed in Kansas City with her mom. They bounced from place to place. Along the way her mom started dating a new guy. It was a very unsafe relationship he wasn't a nice man. Over the next few years, Christa remembers many nights of being woken up by yelling.
克里斯塔·桑多的童年早期是在不同地方的不同住所中模糊度过的。我们住在宾夕法尼亚州、俄亥俄州、德克萨斯州、伊利诺伊州，然后我在10岁时到了堪萨斯城，所以搬家次数很多。在她10岁那年，父母离婚了。克里斯塔的爸爸搬到了芝加哥，克里斯塔和妈妈留在了堪萨斯城。他们从一个地方搬到另一个地方。一路上，她妈妈开始和一个新男人约会。那是一段非常不安全的关系，他不是个好人。在接下来的几年里，克里斯塔记得许多个夜晚被叫喊声惊醒。
It scared her. And I would crawl out of bed and I would get down and I would put my ear to the vent. You know, and it's really hard to ask a 12-year-old to do a Thessa situation if you're going to need to call 911 or to get your mom help. Krista never talked to anyone about what was going on or how it felt to her. Instead, she just buried it all inside. Because her home life felt chaotic, Krista loved school. She still remembers kind teachers who nurtured her and made her feel safe. But she also vividly remembers the unkind ones who seemed to enjoy dispensing little
这让她感到害怕。我会爬下床，趴在通风口上听。你知道，要求一个12岁的孩子去处理这种如果你需要拨打911或寻求帮助的情况真的很难。克里斯塔从未向任何人谈论过发生了什么或她的感受。相反，她只是把一切都埋在心里。因为她的家庭生活感到混乱，克里斯塔热爱学校。她仍然记得那些培养她并让她感到安全的善良老师。但她也清楚地记得那些似乎喜欢施加一点点
cruelties. She had a particularly hard time interacting with her middle school music teacher. She was just right on me and she had like a snappy voice. It was like snap, snap, snap when she spoke to me. I felt it almost like in my brain I would leave band and I would just feel that snap, snap of her voice in my head and just not being enough. And I mean trying so hard to play the music and keep my posture. It almost, it just was overwhelming.
残忍的刻薄老师。她在与初中音乐老师互动时遇到了特别大的困难。她总是针对我，而且说话声音很尖锐。她跟我说话时就像“啪、啪、啪”。我感觉它几乎就像在我的大脑里，我会离开乐队，我只会感觉到她声音中那种“啪、啪”声在我的脑海里，感觉自己不够好。我的意思是，我非常努力地演奏音乐并保持姿势。这几乎，这简直让人难以承受。
It just killed any love that I had for music. I quit. I stopped playing. I just gave it all up because it only brought me pain because I felt like I was so terrible. Like I couldn't do it right. You know, here's another person I can't please in my life. All of us have experienced moments like this when we have felt lonely and insecure, when shame and humiliation wash over us, but like most everyone else, Christa stuffed these bad memories into the back of her mind. As she got older, other slights, grown up slights,
它扼杀了任何我对音乐的热爱。我退出了。我停止了演奏。我放弃了一切，因为它只给我带来痛苦，因为我觉得自己太糟糕了。就像我做不好一样。你知道，这是我生命中另一个我无法取悦的人。我们所有人都经历过这样的时刻，当我们感到孤独和不安全时，当羞耻和羞辱感淹没我们时，但像大多数人一样，克里斯塔把这些糟糕的记忆塞进了脑海深处。随着她长大，其他的轻视，成年人的轻视，
got stashed away too. Once when she was in college, she fell for a young man she'd met at a fraternity. She was a freshman, he was two years ahead of her. When we talked on the phone a little bit and I'm still, you know, just like glowing with excitement and he asked if I wanted to go there was going to be a party and if I wanted to go with him and I thought, oh my gosh, this is great. Yes, I want to go with you." Christa spent hours preparing for the date. She picked out her favorite green blouse and put hot rollers in her hair. I wanted my hair all curled and ready to go. He picked her up to take her to the party.
也被藏了起来。有一次她在大学时，她爱上了一个在兄弟会认识的年轻人。她是新生，他比她高两届。当我们通了一点电话，我仍然，你知道，只是因为兴奋而容光焕发，他问我是否想去，那里会有一个派对，问我是否想和他一起去，我想，天哪，这太棒了。是的，我想和你一起去。克里斯塔花了几个小时准备约会。她挑选了她最喜欢的绿色衬衫，并把热卷发器卷在头发上。我想要我的头发卷好，准备出发。他开车接她去参加派对。
Everything seemed great until they got there. Then it was as if Christa didn't exist. He walked off to join his friends and never returned. But that's when I realized I'm like, this guy doesn't like you. This guy's kind of a jerk. Christa even told himself. I went up to him, I can see it now, he's dancing with a bunch of girls, you know, red solo cup in his hand. And I
一切看起来都很棒，直到他们到达那里。然后就好像克里斯塔不存在一样。他走开去加入他的朋友们，再也没有回来。但就在那时我意识到，我想，这个家伙不喜欢你。这个家伙是个混蛋。克里斯塔甚至告诉自己。我走到他身边，我现在还能看到，他和一群女孩跳舞，你知道，手里拿着红色的塑料杯。而我
said, I'm gonna leave with my friends. This is not for me." And he said, that's good. And I said, why? And he said, because your friends are permanent and I'm only temporary. And I thought, oh my gosh, like that is stuck with me forever. Like, he never liked me. I was just some chick going to a party with them. And that right there, I just, oh, it wounded me. I was so mad at myself for seeing a situation so wrong. In the years I've followed, Krista settled in Denver and got married, not to a jerk, but to a really nice guy. They had two sons. Life was pretty great. But then one day, her left eye began to give her trouble.
说：‘我要和朋友们一起走了，这不适合我。’他说：‘那很好。’我问：‘为什么？’他说：‘因为你的朋友是永久的，而我只是暂时的。’我想，天哪，这句话永远刻在了我的心里。原来他从来没喜欢过我，我只是个和他们一起去派对的女孩。那一刻，我真的……哦，它伤害了我。我对自己感到非常生气，因为我把情况看得太错了。在接下来的几年里，克里斯塔在丹佛定居并结了婚，嫁的不是个混蛋，而是一个非常好的人。他们有两个儿子，生活相当美满。但有一天，她的左眼开始出现问题。
She went to the doctor who sent Krista for an MRI. Immediately after the scan, she learned what was wrong. She had MS, multiple sclerosis. I can remember those first few days, you know, we took the kids downtown to get ice cream and I remember just like sitting there thinking everything is different now. Everything in our life is going to be different now. And I didn't know how different. And I didn't know how it was going to impact the kids or if my absentee was going to have to take care of me. It was pretty rough. I really retreated inside myself. But then a good friend sent Christa a gift, a romance novel.
她去看医生，医生让克里斯塔去做了核磁共振。扫描后，她立刻知道了问题所在。她患了多发性硬化症（MS）。我记得最初的那几天，我们带孩子们去市中心吃冰淇淋，我记得当时坐在那里想，现在一切都变了。我们生活中的一切现在都要变了。我不知道会变得多不同，也不知道这会如何影响孩子们，或者我的丈夫是否必须照顾我。那段日子相当艰难。我真的退缩到了自己的内心世界。但后来，一位好朋友送给克里斯塔一份礼物，一本浪漫小说。
And I thought, what are you doing? But why would you send this to someone diagnosed with a disease that nobody can cure and she's like just read it? It's exactly what you need. So Christa did as she was told. She read the book. Oh, it's got such a naughty title. It's called Man Hoar by Katie Evans.
我想，你在做什么？为什么要把这个送给一个被诊断出患有无法治愈疾病的人？她说：‘读读看，这正是你需要的。’所以克里斯塔照做了。她读了那本书。哦，它的书名真够淘气的，叫《Man Whore》，作者是凯蒂·埃文斯。
But it's a wonderful, wonderful book, a wonderful series. It was the escape that I needed. So, for a whole year, that's all I did. It was audiobook romance. I just, you know, between five and seven books a week. Krista, listen what she was folding laundry. I wasn't looking to fall in love. I wasn't looking to lose my mind and common sense over the most beautiful green eyes I have ever seen.
但这是一本非常棒的书，一个非常棒的系列。它是我所需要的逃避。所以，整整一年，我只做了这件事。就是听浪漫有声书。我每周听五到七本书。克里斯塔在叠衣服时听着。我并不是在寻找爱情，我并不是在寻找那种为了我见过的最美丽的绿眼睛而失去理智和常识的感觉。
She listened as she drove the kids to play dates. I wasn't looking to drive myself crazy with lust. She listened at the grocery store. Standing in the produce at Whole Foods, it was a very Colorado moment. And I remember there was a steamy scene and I was just like standing there. We scrambled about arms and legs twisting this way in that.
她开车带孩子们去玩的时候听着。我并不是在寻找那种让自己因欲望而疯狂的感觉。她在杂货店听着。站在全食超市的农产品区，那是一个非常科罗拉多的时刻。我记得里面有一个火辣的场景，我就那样站在那里。我们纠缠在一起，四肢扭动着。
Looking at like a whole row of like bell peppers. When I realized I was gonna die, the only thing I could think about was you. I must have been there for 10 minutes. I couldn't stop dreaming about him. You can zone out in the produce department in Colorado. I mean, I was waiting for someone to Namaste me. I want to make you blush from here to the tips of your feet.
看着一整排的甜椒。当我意识到我要死的时候，我唯一能想到的就是你。我一定在那里站了10分钟。我无法停止梦见他。在科罗拉多的农产品区，你可以完全放空。我的意思是，我在等有人对我行合十礼。我想让你从头到脚都脸红。
I wasn't ready to like turn it off and then go order my hamburger meat. He's the first beautiful thing I've ever seen that actually hurts to look at. The books became a lifeline. They held her fear at bay. For the first year after my diagnosis, There was hardly five minutes, 10 minutes go by where I just didn't think about MS or having MS or I'm with my kids and I'm like, no, my kids have a mom with MS.
我还没准备好关掉它，然后去点我的汉堡肉。他是我见过的第一个美到让人看一眼都觉得心痛的东西。这些书成了救命稻草。它们让她的恐惧远离。在我确诊后的第一年，几乎没有五分钟、十分钟的时间里，我不去想多发性硬化症，或者患有这种病，或者我和孩子们在一起时，我会想，不，我的孩子们有一个患有多发性硬化症的妈妈。
It was just this constant loop in my mind when I was kind of alone or even just, with the kids doing anything, I've just popped right into my brain all the time and I found the only time where it really was gone was when I was immersed in these stories and these characters' lives. After about a year of obsessively listening to Romances, Krista made a big decision. She wasn't just going to read romances, she was going to write them. And I said, I think I'm going to, you know, dust off that English minor, and I think I'm
这在我脑海中形成了一个持续的循环，当我独自一人，或者即使只是和孩子们做任何事情时，它总是会突然跳进我的脑海。我发现唯一真正消失的时候，就是我沉浸在这些故事和这些角色的生活中时。在痴迷地听了大约一年的浪漫小说后，克里斯塔做出了一个重大决定。她不仅要读浪漫小说，还要写浪漫小说。我说，我想我要掸掉那个英语辅修专业的灰尘，我想我
going to do this, I'm going to write a book. Krista wasn't interested in the kind of romances her grandmother had devoured, the ones featuring damsels and distress and the swarthy men who carry them off. Krista liked contemporary romances. I was kind of more drawn to these kind of powerful women in charge of their sexuality, you know, kick an ass and solve and crimes. Now Krista was an unknown.
要做到这一点，我要写一本书。克里斯塔对她祖母那一代人沉迷的浪漫小说不感兴趣，那种以落难少女和带走她们的粗犷男人为主角的小说。克里斯塔喜欢当代浪漫小说。我更倾向于那些掌控自己性欲、踢屁股和解决犯罪的强大女性。当时克里斯塔还是个无名小卒。
She had never published before. She didn't have an agent or inside contacts. So she self-published. She called her first book, The Road Home. It's about a woman confronting her past and finding danger and love. The book was a huge success. And then it became two books and then it became a five book series and then another three book series. It's bloomed and blossomed into something really wonderful.
她以前从未出版过作品。她没有经纪人，也没有内部人脉。所以她选择了自出版。她把第一本书命名为《回家的路》（The Road Home）。它讲述了一个女人面对过去并发现危险与爱情的故事。这本书取得了巨大的成功。然后变成了两本书，接着是一个五部曲系列，然后又是另一个三部曲系列。它绽放并开花结果，变成了一些非常美妙的东西。
The books did more for Christa than make her a star author. They allowed her to explore and then reimagine the painful memories she had stored away in the back of her head. It started with that first book, The Road Home. In it, Krista created a character that was modeled on her own mother, who passed away some years ago. First I thought, well maybe I should just write about her, and then I decided, no, I'm going to, you know, I'm going to write this romance. I'm going to make this situation okay for the heroin.
这些书对克里斯塔的意义远不止让她成为明星作家。它们让她能够探索并重新构想那些她储存在脑海深处的痛苦记忆。这一切始于第一本书《回家的路》。在书中，克里斯塔创造了一个以她已故母亲为原型的角色。起初我想，也许我应该只写她，然后我决定，不，我要写这本浪漫小说。我要让女主角的这种情况变得好起来。
She's going to get through what I was kind of going through with my mother at the time. In the book, the heroin's mother is Judith Lewis. She has a boyfriend named Travis. Here's Krista, reading from the road home. Travis and Judith were the Bonnie and Clyde of narcissism and irresponsibility, moving from town to town living only for themselves. The relationship was always tumultuous like a roller coaster, about to fly off the rails
她会度过我当时和母亲经历的那种困境。在书中，女主角的母亲是朱迪思·刘易斯。她有一个男朋友叫特拉维斯。这是克里斯塔在朗读《回家的路》。特拉维斯和朱迪思是自恋和不负责任的邦妮和克莱德，从一个城镇搬到另一个城镇，只为自己而活。这段关系总是像过山车一样动荡，随时准备脱轨。
at any moment. But now, knowing that Judith suffered from bipolar disorder, Jenna could better understand her mother's behavior, as well as her attraction to Travis. They both lived for the high and needed a constant stream of drama to survive. Krista says in creating the characters, she finally got to voice what it had felt like
但现在，知道朱迪思患有双相情感障碍，珍娜能更好地理解她母亲的行为，以及她对特拉维斯的吸引力。他们都靠追求刺激为生，需要不断的戏剧性事件才能生存。克里斯塔说，在塑造这些角色时，她终于能够表达出她作为小孩子时的感受。
for her as a small child, seeing her caregivers nearly come to blows with one another. I got to show them who they really were, what I really thought, what it was like, you know, being a child who kind of had to live with two people, so obsessed with their own kind of their own knees, their own wants, and then throw in that whole drinking and partying. So, yeah, so this first book was really allowed me to delve into it and kind of get my own say. Have a say that I never got to say. I think it's fascinating.
看着照顾她的人几乎要大打出手。我有机会向他们展示他们到底是谁，我到底是怎么想的，作为一个不得不和两个只沉迷于自己的需求、自己的欲望的人生活在一起的孩子是什么感觉，再加上酗酒和聚会。所以，是的，这本书真的让我深入其中，并表达了我自己的观点。拥有一个我从未有机会表达的观点。我觉得这很迷人。
They're almost trying to master what happened to you. You're almost processing what happened to you. And by putting it into the lives of characters, in some ways you're able to, in some ways, do what people do in therapy, which is to hold their own experiences at some distance and look at themselves and look at their own lives and look at their own experiences with some degree of objectivity and allows you to get new insight into what actually happened to you. Is that the way it felt for you, Christa? Absolutely, and I think it brought, even though what I wrote was harsh or, you know, maybe could be conceived as cruel,
他们几乎是在试图掌握发生在你身上的事情。你几乎是在处理发生在你身上的事情。通过将它放入角色的生活中，在某种程度上，你能够像人们在治疗中所做的那样，即保持一定的距离来看待自己的经历，审视自己，审视自己的生活，并以某种客观性来看待自己的经历，这让你对发生在你身上的事情有了新的洞察。克里斯塔，你感觉是这样吗？绝对是，而且我认为它带来了，即使我写的东西很刺耳，或者可能被认为是残酷的，
it actually helped me understand these characters more. She also got to do what Julie Bolton talked about, reframe stories and rewrite how they ended. So the frat boy who dumped her at the party, Krista turned him into a loser. I mean, we had to really stick the knife in and then give her a nice little turn. We leave him as just some douchebag in a bar, you know. That's where we leave him.
它实际上帮助我更了解这些角色。她还做到了朱莉·博尔顿所说的，重构故事并改写结局。所以那个在派对上甩了她的兄弟会男生，克里斯塔把他变成了一个失败者。我的意思是，我们必须狠狠地捅他一刀，然后给她一个漂亮的转折。我们让他只是酒吧里的一个混蛋，你知道。这就是我们让他停留的地方。
The teacher who's constantly snapping drove Krista away from music. She became Mindy Lancaster, a Dauer woman constantly trying to belittle the heroin. In Krista's new version, it was the heroine, Emma, who got the last word. What if she couldn't do it? What if her fingers had forgotten? What was one second nature? She met Mindy's gaze and saw a glimmer of triumph
那个不断咆哮的老师让克里斯塔远离了音乐。她变成了明迪·兰开斯特，一个不断试图贬低女主角的刻薄女人。在克里斯塔的新版本中，是女主角艾玛说了最后的话。如果她做不到怎么办？如果她的手指忘记了曾经的本能怎么办？她迎上明迪的目光，看到了一丝胜利的光芒
flash in the woman's eyes. Mindy was an accomplished pianist, but she never risen to even a fraction of what Emma achieved as a musician. A confidence Emma hadn't known in years surged through her veins. I'll do fine without the sheet music Mrs. Lancaster. I guess you don't remember,
在那个女人的眼中闪过。明迪是一位有成就的钢琴家，但她从未达到艾玛作为音乐家所取得成就的哪怕一小部分。一种艾玛多年未有的自信涌入她的血管。没有乐谱我也能做得很好，兰开斯特夫人。我想你不记得了，
but I mastered these pieces by my fourth birthday. Maybe it was my fifth but who's counting? The anger that kept her away from music, away from the memories that threatened to tear her apart with guilt and grief was transforming. I've performed for the Queen of England. I think I can handle this. Writing Mindy Lancaster, Christa, says, was deeply healing.
但我四岁时就掌握了这些曲子。也许是五岁，但谁在乎呢？那种让她远离音乐、远离那些因内疚和悲伤而几乎将她撕裂的记忆的愤怒正在转化。我曾为英国女王表演过。我想我能应付这个。克里斯塔说，写明迪·兰开斯特的过程具有深刻的治愈作用。
It was surprisingly cathartic. You know, I'd never said anything. As a child, I just stopped playing. I just, I never got the chance to say to this woman, you know, you took something very important away from me, and I'm angry about it. After she put all her grief and rage into the fantasy, Krista says something amazing happened. I have exposed every raw feeling that I had about that situation and that brings me sort of a peacefulness that it's out there.
这出奇地具有宣泄作用。你知道，我以前什么都没说。小时候，我只是停止了演奏。我只是，我从来没有机会对这个女人说，你知道，你从我这里夺走了一些非常重要的东西，我对此感到愤怒。在将所有的悲伤和愤怒投入到幻想中后，克里斯塔说发生了一些神奇的事情。我已经暴露了关于那种情况的所有原始感受，这给我带来了一种平静，因为它已经表达出来了。
It almost cleared the way to remember that there were happier memories. It just's also the fact that it's brought you success. I mean, so, you've actually taken this pain and you've transmuted it almost literally into gold. Yeah, it's become my career. My husband's like, how many jerks did you date? Because we need some more books. I tell people I dated every jerk in Denver before I met my husband, so I'm like, honey, you don't have to worry. Between college and dating, we're golden.
它几乎扫清了障碍，让人想起还有更快乐的记忆。这也确实是因为它给你带来了成功。我的意思是，你实际上已经把这种痛苦转化，几乎字面上变成了黄金。是的，它成了我的职业。我丈夫问，你到底约会过多少个混蛋？因为我们需要更多的书。我告诉人们，在遇到我丈夫之前，我约会过丹佛的每一个混蛋，所以我说，亲爱的，你不用担心。在大学和约会之间，我们赚翻了。
So it is just really interesting to take all the heartache and kind of spin it into gold. With each new book, Christa Sandor has felt like the burdens she has carried have grown lighter and lighter. The themes of anger and sadness have given way to laughter and comedy. Writing for her has been like a cleansing rain, washing away bad memories and hurt. It is put our in touch with all the good things in her life. Many of us never think to put pen to paper or we sit down and start but then hesitate because we're afraid of what our stories mean, what our fantasies might reveal. But when we do this, we not only miss out on how our stories might transform other people.
所以把所有的心碎变成黄金真的很有趣。随着每一本新书的出版，克里斯塔·桑多尔感到她背负的负担越来越轻。愤怒和悲伤的主题已经让位于欢笑和喜剧。写作对她来说就像一场洗涤的雨，冲走了糟糕的记忆和伤害。它让她重新接触到生活中所有美好的事物。我们许多人从没想过要动笔，或者我们坐下来开始写，但随后又犹豫了，因为我们害怕我们的故事意味着什么，我们的幻想可能会揭示什么。但当我们这样做时，我们不仅错过了我们的故事如何改变他人的机会，
We miss out on the power of stories to transform us. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, Andrew Chadwick, Kristen Wong and Laura Quarelle. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks this week to one of our favorite storytellers, former Hidden Brain producer, Jenny Schmidt, who played a vital role in this episode.
我们还错过了故事改变我们自己的力量。Hidden Brain 由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、奥特姆·巴恩斯、瑞安·卡茨、安德鲁·查德威克、克里斯汀·王和劳拉·夸雷尔。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是 Hidden Brain 的执行编辑。本周特别感谢我们最喜欢的故事讲述者之一，前 Hidden Brain 制作人珍妮·施密特，她在本集中发挥了至关重要的作用。
Thanks as well to our voice actors this week, Rachel Danzig, Scott Sylvestero, and Nicholas Otto. Our unsung hero this week is Matt Wheelan. Matt is my editor at Norton & Company, the publisher of my new book Useful Delusions. The idea that we explored today, how stories shaped the way we see the world, is also a central theme of useful delusions. Over several years, Matt helped me and my co-author Bill Meshler refine our ideas. But even more than a skill as an editor, Matt has always been kind and wise, the best kind of friend, and the ideal unsung hero. I can see his influence all over today's story as well. Thanks Matt. This
同样感谢本周的配音演员瑞秋·丹齐格、斯科特·西尔维斯特罗和尼古拉斯·奥托。我们本周的无名英雄是马特·惠兰。马特是我新书《有用的错觉》（Useful Delusions）出版商诺顿公司的编辑。我们今天探讨的想法，即故事如何塑造我们看待世界的方式，也是《有用的错觉》的核心主题。几年来，马特帮助我和我的合著者比尔·梅什勒完善了我们的想法。但比起作为编辑的技能，马特一直很善良和睿智，是最好的朋友，也是理想的无名英雄。我今天的故事中到处都能看到他的影响。谢谢你，马特。这
episode is part of a series on how we make sense of the world. If you haven't had a chance to listen already, check out last week's episode about how we use explanations to bring order to an otherwise chaotic world. Next week, we explore how culture shapes the stories we tell ourselves. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一集是我们关于我们如何理解世界系列的一部分。如果你还没有机会收听，请查看上周关于我们如何利用解释为混乱的世界带来秩序的那一集。下周，我们将探讨文化如何塑造我们对自己讲述的故事。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。